fun
because a pod boy's not been going even
harder and going more into the whole you
know background of this little
relationship with Bobby Lee kalila and
all that
but you guys don't know what status
Bobby and I are I want to point
something out this is from when they
were doing the show during the pandemic
and I want you to look at a couple
things merch look at the bottom left
quadrant
what you're seeing is a glass barrier in
between Bobby and kalila and the guest
and look at the producer what you're
looking at is a producers inside of a
glass box and wearing a mask
these people are [ __ ] insane they are
really sick we don't after that one
episode we have no idea yeah you'll
never know you'll never know so you're
turning 50
so you're not going to have a party
you're not going to do anything I was
gonna have a big shindig I was gonna and
also I'm gonna pretend like I wasn't
friends
with that chick from Smallville even
though we're really close friends
because now that she's crazy and she was
in Nexium
you know that's Lex oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I remember also I mean can you just
turn the lights on though I bet like one
of them broke and he hasn't got them
fixed you're right right now it just
says interview
I was going to invite as as many people
as I could so remember you said that
they're not that they weren't married
but watch this I was gonna get a
restaurant I was gonna invite as as many
people as I could but then Delta
happened so can't you get some friends
together like me no I I can't do it
because of um
because of kalila what do you mean you
can't do it because of your wife no she
she I didn't realize you're married I
know you're married I know you do know
that's good you know that do you think
we're married I think you're married I
think you got married in 2016 and you
really didn't tell people
we are married yeah
earlier he said she's not remember we
played Clips because she's not my wife
we're not married this I know seems
silly but why would you lie about that
you guys already living together but
number one number two this then
coinciding with she owns tigerbelly this
is weird this is all weird right I
destroyed him she really is truly a
succubus yeah also uh Michael Rosenbaum
you could have less [ __ ] you could have
less tchotchkes Studio I'm sorry but let
me pull up let me let me let me do a
long shot because I know exactly what
you're talking about I know exactly what
you're talking about and I want to point
that out because I love that to be to be
fair to him this is a little older and
it's and I've seen those other
interviews and he doesn't it doesn't
look like it's not cluttered anymore but
yeah bro come on Manny thing can we can
we go through it okay number one
all okay we get it you like horror
movies no less than 10 horror movie
posters because there's another row of
them up off camera
then the Indiana Jones thing and then
which doesn't go with the motif if this
is going to be a horror Motif then you
know keep it horror Motif and good yes
merch is a good point there's the second
level of [ __ ] things like you're at
the goddamn Haunted Mansion in Disney
World and then you have the C3 appeal
there which is like that doesn't go with
the horror theme what's that about but
then the thing that bothers me the most
there's three things in the room that
bother me the relaxed thing is one let's
play Highlights magazine okay uh what's
but the other two should be easy look
Nexus 3c3po on both sides just oh my God
there's two more of them that to me he
said is like get a live laugh love thing
at that point right
you know what that is that's the sign of
an insecure washed up actor who [ __ ]
is probably a neurotic mess he's
probably a neurotic self-hating mess and
he has to have slitter he's so [ __ ]
sick in his head that he has to have
signs all over his house reminding him
to relax and breathe can I go can I go
one even more for you
this is a converted garage
want to know how you could tell the the
guy to the right of Bobby Lee behind him
there's a controller for one of these
which is like a portable AC unit right
and that's what they do when you convert
it because you can't run ductwork in a
garage
property taxes because if that's
that's my room is bigger than that room
like that's a small room right yeah
that's true I know you do know that's
good you know that do you think we're
married I think you're married I think
you got married in 2016. and you really
didn't tell people
we are married yeah
listen let's talk about us okay I I I I
I think I'm at a point right now that I
want to talk about us okay fine okay so
that's pretty much a clip I just thought
it was funny because they kept saying
you know she's not he was very clear
like oh we're not married we're not
married so this is a little Quick Clip
of uh it's only a minute so we could
yeah we could do this our fellow Rumble
host Dr Drew Dr Drew yes
um this is a little oh this is about
about six months ago I want to say where
this is from but here you go I I got my
ass beat more wasn't spanked my mom
coined the term stomach belt so she she
picked up a belt to hit you with it yeah
in the stomach with a belt end over the
vocal Endeavor
um not the Buckle end but she did make
us nylon salt like rock salt Neal and
salt yeah like until it over time it
doesn't seem like a painful Endeavor at
first but two hours and you're like oh
this your mother made you kneel on salt
for two everything you sees a lie I
don't believe you it kind of hurts my
kneecaps is that what you jerked off
dogs
you still have scarring no I don't
but that's she punched me so hard in my
mouth one time that it took me three
hours to unplug three hours my brace is
wire from my lips
I remember hiding in the trash can for
like the my neighbor's trash can for two
hours and she well it must have felt
like home because you're [ __ ] garbage
that's what he's gonna hone in on
everything oh yeah yeah it's two hours
three hours four hours which is I could
hear her circling the neighborhood like
where the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] you know but
you know what we were laughing about
over dinner like hysterically was a time
I ran away from home and hid in a trash
can for three hours it took him three
hours to find me I was so afraid my mom
was just gonna beat my ass for something
so small like leaving a shampoo bottle
did you use the thing as a shield where
you're like she's just garbage she looks
like a pile of dirty clothes on the
floor I know but you know what Marsh
I'd Rumble through it and sniff it to
see if I'd still wear it I'd still wear
that shirt you've done that where you're
like that's all I have you you know you
go through and you're like this one
passes
you know maybe all your laundry is dirty
and it's 2 A.M on a Saturday at a bar
and you go do that dirty laundry pile
you know look man sometimes you spray it
with for B for Breeze and you move on
sometimes sometimes that dirty uh those
dirty jeans are the only thing you're
going to be able to get into oh that
[ __ ] really good point you gotta you
gotta get by you got to go to the store
you got to run errands I try not to trip
over her Frankenstein shoes in the
morning Christ seriously
laughs
Grandpa Grandpa
looks it started to stop you started
doing a dance
thank you po boy we really do appreciate
it but yeah it's three hours bro I was
in a garbage can for three hours with
rock salt